>> Leo: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU FOR A
LONG TIME THAT ON THIS SHOW, THE
BORDER CRISIS IS OUT OF CONTROL
AND NOW FINALLY, DHS SECRETARY
AGREES.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID TO BORDER
PATROL AND LEAKED AUDIO OBTAINED
BY US, FOX NEWS.
LISTEN.
>> THIS IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
WE CAN CONTINUE LIKE THIS.
OUR SYSTEM HAS NOT BEEN BUILT
FOR IT.
>> Leo: A RARE MOMENT OF
HONESTY BUT DON'T EXPECT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO MAKE A BIG
DEAL OUT OF THE STORY OR THE
RECORD-BREAKING NUMBER OF
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS IN JULY.
ACCORDING TO NEWS BUSTERS, THE
NETWORK IGNORED THAT STORY BUT
WERE EAGER TO COVER
BRITNEY SPEARS CONSERVATORSHIP
BATTLES.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA,
TOM HOMAN, AND SARA CARTER.
LET ME JUST GO TO YOU RIGHT NOW.
I WILL GO TO TOM POLITICO TO TOM
FIRST.
I FIND THE LEAKED AUDIO AND
ADMISSION OF FAILURE.
>> SEVEN MONTHS, THE SECRETARY
HAS LIED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
SAYING THE BORDER IS SECURE AND
CANNOT GO DOWN TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND TELL THEM THAT
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO MAKE IT
OBVIOUS BECAUSE YOU ARE DEALING
WITH THIS EVERY DAY.
SO I AM CONVINCED HE DIDN'T KNOW
HE WAS BEING TAPED OR HE
WOULDN'T HAVE SAID THAT BUT THIS
BORDER IS NOT SECURE, IT IS NOT
CLOSED, WE HAVE OVER A MILLION
APPREHENSIONS BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION UNDER THIS
PRESIDENT, 200,000 PEOPLE
RELEASED, MANY WITH COVID,
FENTANYL COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER IN RECORD NUMBERS,
TRAFFICKING IS UP, OVER 20
BORDER AGENTS DIED OF COVID.
TOOK THE MOST SECURE BORDER I'VE
SEEN IN MY ENTIRE CAREER AND
MADE AT THE MOST OUT OF CONTROL
BORDER.
THIS BORDER IS A DISASTER IN THE
SHORT TIME HE'S BEEN PRESIDENT.
I'VE SEEN NOTHING LIKE THIS.
>> Leo: THIS SITUATION,
BRITNEY SPEARS SITUATION IS A
SMOKING SCREEN TYPE OF SCENARIO
BECAUSE A LEFT-WING MEDIA WANTS
TO FOCUS ON BRITNEY SPEARS BUT
THEY DON'T WANT TO FOCUS ON WHAT
IS AFFECTING EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE ILLEGAL MIGRATION
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS AND WHAT THEY
TALK ABOUT HAVING THOUSANDS OF
THESE PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER
WITH COVID, HOW DO THEY GET AWAY
WITH IT?
>> I WAS JUST THERE, JUST
RETURNED FROM TEXAS, THE
RESIDENTS ALL ACROSS THE BORDER,
THE RESOURCES ARE STRAINED,
FRUSTRATED, THEY SEE A RISE IN
COVID, 400 BORDER PATROL AGENTS
WHO WERE AT HOME AND HAVING TO
STAY OFF DUTY FOR AT LEAST TWO
WEEKS AND OTHERS WHO HAVE PASSED
AWAY AND OF COURSE, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
YOU REALLY CARE, IF
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE TRULY
CARES ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING IN HERE, THEN HE WILL
STOP THIS BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER ARE BEING TRAFFIC BY
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, DRUG CARTELS
ARE BEING EXPLOITED.
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS A
DEVASTATING SITUATION ON THE
BORDER AND I CAN TELL YOU A LOT
OF DHS OFFICIALS I'VE SPOKEN TO,
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE SAYING
FLAT OUT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
DERELICT IN HIS DUTIES.
>> Leo: I AGREE WITH THAT.
I KNOW YOU ARE A BIG
BRITNEY SPEARS FAN, BUT WE HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THE BORDER AND I'M
ASKING YOU SERIOUSLY FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF HOW THE MEDIA CAN
BASICALLY BE IN BED WITH
JOE BIDEN FOCUSED ON EVERYTHING
BUT THIS CRISIS OF THE BORDER
AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
WHAT IS HE LOOKING AT?
HOW DID HE GET AWAY WITH IT FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME?
>> WE WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO SHARE
THE WHOLE BRITNEY SPEARS THING,
MY FIRST SONG OF THE DAY EVERY
DAY IS TOXIC BUT IT IS A TOXIC
SITUATION OF THE BORDER AS I
TRANSITION OUT OF THAT AWKWARD
TRANSITION.
AXIOS IS NOW REPORTING THAT
50,000 MIGRANTS WERE RELEASED
INTO THE U.S. WITHOUT A COURT
DATE AND PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE FOR MORE THAN 200
DAYS AND HAS YET TO VISIT THE
BORDER WHICH IS IN CRISIS AND
PERHAPS THAT'S WHY IT'S BEEN
MORE THAN 90 DAYS SINCE HE IS
DONE A A ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEW
AND THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM
OPPRESSOR BECAUSE HALFWAY DECENT
JOURNALIST WHO CARES ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THERE ARE A
FEW OUT THERE WOULD PRESS THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE GIVES A VAGUE
GENERIC ANSWER.
IN THE CASE OF THE BORDER, ONE
WOULD HAVE TO HAMMER HOME THE
NUMBERS YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT,
READ BACK THE QUOTES FROM
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS AND BORDER
STATES IN TOWN SAYING THIS IS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, SHOW HIM
PHOTOS OF FACILITIES THAT THREE,
FOUR, 500% CAPACITY AND ASK HIM
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN AND HOW COULD
YOU SAY YOUR VICE PRESIDENT IS
DOING A GOOD JOB?
AGAIN, BUT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
IN CHARGE OF SOLVING THIS CRISIS
OF THE BORDER WHICH IS A
FASCINATING CHOICE WHEN YOU
CONSIDER HARRIS AGREE THAT ALL
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS SHOULD
BE MADE LEGAL AND COMPARED ICE
TO THE KKK AND HAS YET TO HOLD
ONE PRESS CONFERENCE ON THIS IN
HER ROLE BEGAN 140 DAYS AGO.
YOU WOULD THINK AFTER THE DIRE
COMMENTS CAUGHT ON TAPE THAT
NBC, CBS AND THE RECENT NEWS
CAST WATCHED BY PUTTING MILLION
PEOPLE WOULD'VE COVERED IT BUT
THEY BARELY TOUCHED IT BECAUSE
BRITNEY SPEARS TOOK MAJOR
PRESIDENT NOT SAYING THAT SHE
HASN'T A STORY BUT THERE'S NO
REASON YOU CAN'T DO BOTH.
BY THE WAY, I WANT TO DEBUT
THIS.
AND IT IS COMPLETELY ORIGINAL,
RIGHT?
I GOT YOU.
>> Leo: I'VE BEEN HAD.
HE GOT ME.
THANK YOU, JOE.
THANK YOU, TOM.
JOE, CAN YOU TELL